僕今中が草木つホストファミリーにいるんですけど僕にまぁちょっと
すみかを変えようと思いますって一応細野ホストファミリーにたまりか
レジデンスって言うように泊まるか決めるんですけど
ちょっと
支援しに行こうかなと思いましてまずこの家から学校がないが5時間かかって
イギリスのバスってけっこう時間が適当なんですよ
ひどい時30分それを持った15分とか
松山市
なかなか遅刻して学校行けなかった時もあるんで
あとなんかねインターネットが夜のに14時になったらまず来られるし
シャアビル時間と朝の7時半からかな7時半から9時半って決まってて
2人日はなんですけどここ机が1個しかなくて
勉強は
その相方が勉強してたら僕はできないんですよね
次のプラス
まあ
これメインじゃないんですけど動画とるときにあまりこういう家族の全く知らない人の
家に泊まらせてもらってるわけなんで
あんまりこう大声出すて動画とか取りづらいんですよ
人が家なんて切り使っちゃいますね
何でも一緒のことを糧に移った方が
自転というかあらゆる面でいいなって思うんですけど
なかなかねいいづらいんですよだってすごい居づらくないですか
家族の人に
家族ましたように
なんかねあなたまで日本日本でも僕はッ
いいづらい人だと思うんですけど球が打者にわかると思いますよ
変えなきゃいけないこんな感じね何かいう時って勇気いりませんか
まさにそんな感じですよ
ホストファミリー人たちいい一夏なんですよ
だからがゆえにいいづらいというか
頑張って行ってみようと思う
ルームメイトの良い人なんですけどちょっと頑張って今週
ちょっと勇気出して行ってみようと思います
ちょっとねこんな動画になっちゃって宝石ないんですけど
現像でございます
おっ
ていた
dea